Crazy Fire ouais tu vois, il y en a un sur
la droite aussi, comme un petit ouais, on
dirait que ce serait peut-être
distrayant si je le mettais dans le cadre même si
je l'ai mis à l'intérieur de la ligne de mon cadre,
ok, alors hélicoptère 324
Victor hélicoptère 324
Victor, bien sûr, tu comprends  parce que je
l'ai dans mon c'est
distrayant
4,500 pour euh 24
Victor ouais ça a l'air vraiment
sympa ok
montons 16 c'est sur 13 pour 12
avec
86 maintenant à Los
Angeles5
définitivement 57
4 avec
si tu l'élargis un peu donc
tu 24 n 7737
ouais 86
27 ouais il y a beaucoup de noir mais
continue juste le
plan ouais mais tu sais tu peux voir cette
ligne riche qui est intéressante ouais tu
vois les trois autres F les deux autres
ici les villes wow ça aide d'avoir la pleine
lune ça n'aide pas
c'est ouais, c'est le cas, et ce
rétroéclairage pendant
des minutes
et pensez-vous que cela fonctionnerait si vous faisiez
un panoramique et une inclinaison vers le haut comme si vous voyiez
la ville à la verticale, puis vous vous incliniez
vers le
feu après
cela, d'accord,
laissez-moi juste euh trier  d'obtenir un peu de
dimensionnement
ici, faites-le très lentement merci
pour
oh nous le referons ouais,
laissez-moi certainement m'élargir un peu plus
aussi c'est en quelque sorte ouais
ça a l'air mieux comme
ça, je suis
petit, allez claquer
quoi de
neuf
nous pourrions faire, tu penses que nous pourrions faire
autre chose euh ouais laisse-moi me laisser
euh ok faisons une pause s'il te plaît s'il te plaît
quand tu dis que c'est restreint peux-
tu aller là-bas mais juste à cette
hauteur ou non, ils doivent être un
peu
plus hauts  celui-là sur cette petite zone sur
la droite va vraiment génial
ouais je veux dire nous pouvons CL plus haut si tu veux
si tu veux juste au-dessus je pense ouais je
pense que ça pourrait être une bonne idée peut-être voir de
ce
côté ouais vérifier l'
altitude
Victor tra  mil à l'est de
la position airb
7 500
5 000 le trafic est tout seul
ouais, voyez-vous que c'est ça, il arrive à
8 000 pieds sur celui-là, ok alors nous allons y
arriver pour que nous puissions commencer avec le tir,
nous
montons, commençons à venir au-dessus du  crête ouais, il
le feu, c'est incroyable, tu vois cette
flamme ouais, nous en sommes si loin, c'est
fou et je pense qu'il est sur le point de faire la
même chose sur la
gauche et de s'approcher de l'hélicoptère, euh deux pour
Victor demandant une montée à 8 000
pieds donc nous obtenons  et passe au dessus de l'
hélicoptère de restriction FR 24 Victory tu
vas te diriger là où maintenant on va vouloir
monter à 8 000 ft puis une
transition au dessus du feu au dessus de la
restriction de vol 84 Victor
en attente attends un peu
hélicoptère 24 Victor V sur approbation  à
8,500 roog
8,500 et base 901 au sol à John
Wayne donc 5554 en maintenant 7,000 Adis
quand tu as REM Los Angeles maintenir
7,000
554 24 Victory contct start 24.1
Rog bonne
journée puis-je fermer cette lumière euh 2 sur ce
no 324 Victor alude maintenir  votre
altitude actuelle, s'il vous plaît, Victor
novembre 4 Victor maintient votre
Al cus 133 actuel, maintenez 7 000 et tournez à droite
vers le cap euh 29ers
Z, nous avons donc un panneau
70009 25, tournez à gauche 2 3 0, continuez l'approche 2
4,65 à droite,
essayons d'attendre la ville derrière
it3 avons-nous une lumière qui brille sur
nous ouais, il y a
quelque chose d'une grosse lumière là-bas, c'est
juste mon phare d'atterrissage pour que ce type
puisse me voir mais oh
désolé qu'est-ce qu'il ruine ou a tiré sur
Pi le pap Bravo novembre Bravo à
moi de maintenir 4 000 tours  à droite cap 2
40 2 4 en bas les
4 000 c'est sympa avec le fond ouais
ouais avec la ville au
fond 85 à
droite cus 133 pour envoyer maintenir
6 000 6 000 cus
1334 Victor était
854 Victor V clim 8 500 approuve d'accord
merci bravo bravo tourner à droite cap
280 2 bra Cactus 133 bonne nuit contact
approche 12 1.3 avant de partir tourne à droite
cap 3 1 Z ok 31 0 213
this3 ouais ok ça
a l'air sympa avec le
fond euh arrête
alors il y en a un qui se passe
ici c'est voir comme si toutes les lumières de la ville sont
de retour ouais  Je sais, ça donne vraiment une bonne
perspective ouais tu les vois sur les murs sur
tes grands écrans oh
ouais alors tout droit ouais ouais
c'est encore mieux plus haut comme ça
parce que tu vois les lumières de la ville à l'
arrière ok alors arrêtons c'est juste
une photo comme ça  nous pourrions perdre les lumières de la ville
à l'arrière ouais si nous continuons à
monter, allons à 8 000 sinon encore vers le sud, laissons tomber, laissons
tomber, il y a
des lumières en
arrière et euh vous savez parce que
nous finirons par regarder en bas  dans
ces flammes ouais, ce serait bien d'avoir
une photo verticale après que ton hor soit
normal, je pense que ce que
je peux
voir
wow wow wow,
quel feu s'appelle-t-il, quel est
le
feu de Santiago comme vers Irvine ouais ouais ouais je
l'ai  sur mon
papier comme totalement à côté du
soutien-gorge de la ville 270 27 soutien-
gorge
tu veux rester ici ou te rapprocher
si nous pouvons nous rapprocher ils pourraient nous donner
une perspective là-dessus nous pouvons survoler directement faisons-
le oh ouais respirons
cette
fumée maintenant  le vent le pousse
ni nous allons faire un zoom arrière lentement
ouais et si vous faites un panoramique à gauche aussi, vous verrez
beaucoup de lumières de la ville Sous la fumée
ouais et la base deux pour Victor s'enregistre
au-dessus du feu de Santiago et nous sommes en
vol depuis environ  45
minutes
oh c'est fou, ça a l'air de
devenir de plus en
plus chaud et puis quand nous aurons dépassé ce, euh,
ce gros à droite, peux-tu
t'incliner sur le feu ouais, je vais certainement
commencer à y travailler ouais,
ne regardent-ils pas celui tout droit
ouais  ok, c'est celui que je veux
aborder,
c'est cool parce que tu vois les lumières de la ville
ouais wow c'est un
Inferno,
ces avions ne fonctionnent pas et j'essaye de ne
pas le faire cette fois, probablement même pas les
hélicoptères W, mais si ça passe au-dessus de la
colline et continue  de l'autre côté,
il y a beaucoup de structures qui attendent là-bas
ouais
comme un volcan ouais ça a l'air TR
hypnotisé
wow tu peux zoomer un peu à l'intérieur je vais
tourner oh tu tournes ouais c'est
ce que je
vois
je vais m'incliner vers le bas  dans l'obscurité
juste pour te donner quelque chose à couper
ouais je pense que c'était plutôt cool ouais je
veux courir à nouveau dans l'autre sens ouais je
vais prendre et nous ferons comme
des plans rapprochés dans l'autre
sens
court comme si j'étais sain mais qui a l'air vraiment
sympa
cette
oreille B 5,
je vais à Maguire sud ou Maguire
nord je vois des flammes rouges du nord de grosses
flammes rouges peux-tu zoomer euh ouais ça
va juste lui donner environ 15 de plus au nord,
c'est toi qui me dis maintenant
qu'ils sont
7155  c'est
parti, tu les as appelés sur la
licorne,
ça a l'air encore mieux de ce
côté merci tu
vas bien mec ouais ouais toujours
éveillé survole à nouveau ou on termine le
plan et
ouais ouais c'est au nord sur Alpha suspendu à
gauche a le feu rra tout le  jusqu'à la
fin, prends à
droite, il y a tes grandes flammes rouges ouais,
d'accord, la fumée
fait 1 9 000
Papa
111 et quel est ton
plan
euh, je suppose que nous allons vous emmener
un peu vers le sud pour vous faire contourner le euh
TFR qui est
le
feu s'allume, bien sûr, d'accord, compris,
allons-nous passer par le haut et revenir
ou à gauche ouais, nous allons juste
au-dessus de l'aéroport dans le nord-est pour l'
entrée, d'accord, merci pour le plan,
j'apprécie, d'accord,
pause wow
wow,
attends, c'est
hors de contrôle, ne bouge pas, ça
brûle, regarde, regarde le
beau feu,
bien qui est sauvage, oh mon
dieu, wow, regarde les silhouettes des
arbres, ouais, c'est
magnifique, Ione, c'est juste que
les gens sont magnifiques,
c'est horrible pour  eux maintenant nous avons besoin d'une
maison
en feu ouais nous le faisons vraiment oh tu vois
ces arbres et ces silhouettes je sais que
c'est sauvage
n'est-ce pas oh nous allons juste prendre cette
photo pendant environ 3 minutes
Guerre folle
wow regarde c'est comme un
regard palpitant à
ça  Je joue avec l'Iris, est-ce que
tu
111, voyons, donne une entrée gauche de
leur wow ouais, ça peut faire
comme si tu faisais ça Stan était cette
fumée qui était de la fumée qui passait à travers, ça
pourrait être une fin mais nous allons juste laisser ça
un  un peu plus parce que c'est tellement incroyable
vraiment mais j'ai une fin si je veux ça
ouais c'était comme un balayage naturel ouais c'était
génial
1181 points
en fait 2
Amer je compense la fumée
ah
c'est comme un gros, un gros gros
filtre neutre qui change à droite  tu vois tous ces
arbres maintenant tu peux les voir
nous allons juste rester là toute la nuit d'
abord
5446 information regarde
ça wow c'est comme si c'était comme une
vague étrange qui le traverse
nous ne les attisons pas avec l'
hélicoptère sont  nous
ouais, d'accord, à
6 000
pieds avec la
fumée, il euh tu veux faire une pause une seconde
euh comme ça ouais
qui d'accord eh bien ouais tu l'es merci, peux-
tu imaginer que nous sommes à 8 500 pieds et je
pense qu'il fait chaud
là-bas, c'est zo  incroyable ouais, nous sommes dans
tout le chemin, mais nous devons
le faire ouais même si ça vibre a b, nous
le réparons après ouais non allez, je dois bouger
un peu juste pour me faire un petit
break oh
ok en quelque sorte  noir ici wow regarde
ça
plus vite tu veux aller un peu
plus vite
un peu ou bouger un peu donc sois moins
vibrant ouais on y va
ouais je zoome un peu
306 si tu veux à partir de là et M 6 000
trck redescend à 6 000
306, il y a un euh TI TFR là-haut sur votre
droite
13h00, faites-moi savoir si vous en avez besoin pour
ça, je ne sais pas
si oui ou
non, d'accord, nous portons le clair ici,
tout ralentit vers l'est, mais euh,
nous ne le faisons pas.  Je ne sais pas où ce TFR est ok, je
sais que ça me va si ça
te va en plus non, ça devrait marcher, ça a l'air
vraiment
sympa ouais c'est
incroyable, ça veut dire que le feu, les
avions de pompiers ne fonctionnent même pas
ouais, est sur le côté droit de toi  a big
big euh oh ouais euh ça juste ici euh pourquoi
voyons voir attends wow ok ok
ça continue éternellement fait quoi
faire avec ça voyons
attends c'est juste un peu abstrait
y
ok
Ben tu vois où nous en sommes euh où j'ai
indiqué  peux-tu euh ouais pouvons-nous en quelque sorte
passer en revue cela, je vais m'incliner dessus et
peut-être tourner un peu euh
ouais
36 maintenir 4 000 jusqu'à 4 000
36 bizarre comme les flammes ont des
lignes bizarres de couleurs différentes à la
place
ang9 a fait quelques
peintures juste après  que nous ferons
des plans très rapprochés, d'
accord, nous
voulons tous faire ce rapprochement de cet arbre en
haut à gauche,
d'accord, vous voyez ce grand arbre, celui-
ci, c'est un peu ce que nous tournions
avant, je pense que nous l'avons eu, donc il y
avait
probablement un  je me rapproche
du Tre, je vais juste
brûler, j'ai un petit Bobble
là-bas, j'ai fait un vœu il y a quelques minutes, ça
marche, tu y vas, ça arrive, il y a
des vibrations ouais qui passent et il y a
comme un gros ouais,
rapproche-toi, il y a un gros ouais peut-être  sur ce
gros plan, ça ouais, je pense que c'est
aussi loin que ça,
ok, c'est ton point de vue whoa voilà,
contact appr
1213 23west
2 peut-être que c'est trop petit dans le ouais, je
pense que oui, ok,
tu vois le truc sur le  bien ouais mets-le
dedans ouais euh monte un peu bien sûr ouais
comme ça
wow ok ici ok oh mon
Dieu ok garde-le garde-le ouais garde-le
comme ça j'essaie de le faire mais je suis un peu
quand nous obtenons  juste dessus, il va
très vite,
tu as dépassé toi, alors ils passeront juste au-delà,
d'accord, donc j'y repense en quelque sorte,
même oh, je vois, est-ce que tu veux que nous le fassions, je vais
juste le garder aussi longtemps que je peux, d'accord
sinon  on va on va faire demi-tour si tu
veux si un survol la vibration va
venir Je
te vois
direct ouais j'ai Direct Direct
ok pouvons-nous nous retourner donc
we3 c'est
incroyable lentement un peu Ben si tu
pouvais ralentir un  un peu d'
accord, prends un peu plus de fumée de ce
côté mais je vais aller assez
verticalement
ouais nous sommes juste dans la fumée
maintenant
ouais passe très vite et passe de
l'autre
côté ouais ouais je pense que c'est
plus bien, on y
va, essayons de faire  30 secondes au
moins tu
peux juste ralentir 0 125
c'est le truc du tu sais
quelque chose comme un 40 contre un c'est le
mouvement de l'hélicoptère c'est euh tu
sais c'est il va tourner assez
vite ouais ce n'est pas toujours ça le fait ça
provoque un
parallaxe et puis après le tir quand
tu as fini avec celui-là ok euh tu
sais ce truc à gauche il y a comme
un ouais ouais ce petit éclat à
gauche ouais essaye de faire comme un gros plan
de ça
ok maintiens
5,2 ok  2 60 sur le cap et jusqu'à
5 200 si tu le mets un peu plus haut
ouais ouais comme ça ouais donc tu vois plus
ok comme ça ouais exactement oh ouais ça a l'
air mieux et essaye de tenir ça pendant une
minute ou
aussi d'accord je  j'essaye wow ça ressemble à des
cheveux ou quelque chose comme ça ouais j'en
ai parlé un peu, monte un peu
pour voir suivre les Flames ouais ouais c'est
tu sais c'est ça bouge c'est ce qu'il
fait oh tu
vois ok alors ne te bouge pas, je viens  il faut le
suivre
ça bouge très vite ça arrive c'est
ça bouge très
vite
wow
4000 W c'est fou il va très très
vite exactement peut-être euh peut-être qu'on va
le mener un peu
14h à
15h00 3 à
16h00 6 miles  Nord-ouest sur 7
76 votre gauche de 9h à
10h00 5 12 miles au sud-ouest en bas du
niveau Navajo 6 000
M
119 119
affirmatif ça s'arrête parce qu'il n'y
a rien d'autre à faire B
ouais
déçu il n'y a pas de maison à construire
rien pas de monde pas de
voiture pas d'
équipe de télé tu vois  comment les bords de l'
objectif sont autof Focus
ouais je me demande si c'est de la chaleur ou tu penses que
c'est euh oh c'est normal c'est normal
ouais c'est parce que nous sommes oh non nous ne sommes pas
bien